[Music]
in january 2021 the tolkien fan site the
onering.net leaked the synopsis for
amazon's upcoming lord of the rings
series
soon after amazon confirmed it was real
but what does it tell us about the show
in its setting
here's what we learned from the lord of
the rings synopsis league
it's been pretty obvious for a while now
that the new series will be set during
middle earth second age
in march 2019 amazon studios released a
series of increasingly detailed maps on
the show's twitter page
culminating with a final image that
clearly showed middle-earth during the
second age of tolkien's writings
the accompanying tweet read welcome to
the second age this got most tolkien
fans pretty excited and with good reason
too
despite being filled with great stories
the second age is a largely
underexplored area of tolkien's
legendarium
because that era spanned some 3 500
years however it was still pretty tough
to nail down just when exactly during
the second age the show was going to be
set
now however things are a little clearer
along with reconfirming the second age
setting the synopsis also mentions that
the show will begin quote
in a time of relative peace this is
important as the latter half of the
second age in particular is anything but
peaceful
chances are this means that the show is
due to begin sometime between the fall
of the original dark lord morgoth and
the re-emergence of his chief lieutenant
sauron
one thing the leaked synopsis mentions
is that the show will take viewers back
to an era in which great powers were
forged
sound familiar yes there's a good chance
amazon is here referring to the forging
of the one ring
as well as the other rings of power
which are crucial to the tale of the
second age
all of the major rings of power were
forged roughly halfway through the
second age
this includes three for the elves seven
for the dwarves nine for the great lords
of men
and one for the dark lord himself
the rings are originally forged and
owned solely by the elves who create
them under the guidance of a disguised
sauron
later when war breaks out between the
elves and sauron the dark lord gathers
all but three of them up and
redistributes them to middle earth's
more easily conquered races
while it's almost certain that the rings
are the great powers mentioned here it
should also be pointed out that the
amazon synopsis could be talking about
something else
specifically middle earth's great
alliances the third age is largely
defined by the free peoples of middle
earth fighting sauron in isolated
pockets but the second age actually
features several major unions
particularly between the races of elves
men and dwarves
the age even ends with the famous last
alliance which takes the battle to
mordor and defeats sauron during the
siege of our door
one phrase from the synopsis that jumps
out is the suggestion that during the
second age
kingdoms rose to glory while there are
many strange new places that the amazon
show will doubtless spend time exploring
several of these rising kingdoms will be
quite familiar or familiar in name at
least
during this period galadriel visits her
future kingdom in lorien for the first
time
while legolas grandfather orifir
establishes a refugee elven kingdom in
the heart of the greenwood the dwarving
kingdom of kazadoom is already ancient
when the second age begins and it plays
a vital role in the politics of western
middle earth gondor is founded toward
the end of the second h2
and elrond establishes rivendell around
halfway through in direct defiance of an
all-powerful
sauron and as for the dark lord himself
in need of a home after his return to
middle earth he carves out a corner of
the map for himself
in the dark and terrible land known as
mordor
amazon synopsis mentions that the second
age is a time in which unlikely heroes
were tested this is a vague yet
tantalizing glimpse into the show's cast
of characters
which for now remains largely shrouded
in mystery sure a few hints have come
out here and there for instance ian
mckellen has said he's up for reprising
his role as gandalf even though the
character doesn't arrive in middle earth
until the third age
on the flip side elrond actor hugo
weaving has made it abundantly clear he
has no plans to come back to tolkien's
world and although many of the show's
cast members have already been announced
for the most part we don't yet know for
sure who's playing who
or if the characters they're playing
have any relation to heroes and villains
we've already seen on screen before
the most solid actor to character
connection that has leaked so far is
that welsh actress morphed clark will be
playing a younger galadriel other
casting leagues have only added to the
confusion by throwing around brand new
character names with no obvious relation
to established tolkien texts
according to an october 2019 report by
deadline english actor joseph maul will
be playing a character named oren who is
intriguingly described as being the lead
villain of the series
other new characters reportedly include
the heroic bellador and a female lead
named tyra played by marquella cavanaugh
it was initially supposed by fans that
these were fake names disguising
well-known characters
however the synopsis states that the
series follows an ensemble cast of
characters both familiar and
new so these could well be the actual
names of brand new characters that have
been made up for the show
unfortunately the new synopsis doesn't
offer up any kind of definitive answer
regarding which heroes will be taken on
the dark lord
it does however suggest that the show
will be bringing in some genuinely fresh
faces with no obvious roots in lord of
the rings lore whether the fans like it
or not
in the lord of the rings gandalf implies
that sauron's potential return wouldn't
be the first time middle earth has been
dominated by the dark lord
sauron needs only this ring to cover all
the lands in a second darkness
so if that's the second darkness that
he's talking about when exactly was the
first
why in the second age of course the
amazon synopsis mentions that at this
time
hope hung by the finest of threads and
the greatest villain that ever flowed
from tolkien's pen
threatened to cover all the world in
darkness these words suggest that the
amazon series will portray sauron's
initial rise to power
including his greatest victories and
near total conquest of all of
middle-earth of course this doesn't just
give amazon the opportunity to put the
show's heroes through the ringer it also
allows the studio to divest him of the
one-dimensional persona that defines him
throughout the lore of the rings
instead the show is likely to introduce
fans to a much more interesting version
of tolkien's iconic villain
sauron's key role in the synopsis
suggests what bands have believed for a
long time that the show will depict the
dark lord in his fairer form while the
sauron of the lord of the rings is a
hideous monstrous figure
or a giant dye if you're watching the
movies he was once able to make himself
appear
well pretty darn sexy more specifically
sauron spends much of the second age
masquerading as anatar the lord of gifts
this charismatic disguise allows the
dark lord to mingle with the elves and
for a while
gain their trust sauron remains in his
fair form for much of this time and only
loses the ability to look like this when
numenor is destroyed towards the end of
the second age
obviously sauron's prettier persona
doesn't make him trustworthy by any
means as yells soon discover for
themselves
nonetheless the chance to betray the
dark lord in this way will likely add
another fascinating layer to a villain
not often associated with nuance or
depth
there's no question that sauron is the
biggest threat to middle earth during
the second and third ages but that
doesn't mean he's the only monster
hiding in the shadows
notably the final sentence of the leaked
synopsis begins with the line from the
darkest depths of the misty mountains
this line has some fascinating
implications for the direction the show
might take
it suggests that viewers will be taken
deeper than the thriving halls of kaza
doom to explore the terrible unexplored
spaces beneath the dwarven kingdom
so what's actually down there well for
one thing there's the balrog known as
durian's bane
you know what they awoke in the darkness
of hazard
shadow and flame this fiery demon isn't
just a terror to all and sundry it's
also fiercely independent having found
itself without a master after the
destruction of morgoth
as such although durin's bane is
supposed to be asleep for much of the
second age it could still turn out to be
an important part of the amazon series
but the malrog isn't the only thing
living beneath the misty mountains
when gandalf discusses his battle under
moria and the two towers
he mentions that far far below the
deepest delvings of the dwarves the
world is gnawed by nameless things
even sauron knows them not they are
older than he considering sauron and the
balrogs fought together in the first age
it's clear that gandalf is referring to
something altogether more horrifying
than durian's bane
and while toki never elaborated on what
creatures lurk in those darkest depths
it seems that the show may just tackle
that question for itself
one of the more specific lines in the
synopsis is the brief mention that the
story will span to the majestic force of
the elf capital of lindon this naturally
leads to the question
what and where is lindon the short
answer is that lindon
is an important elven nation that exists
throughout the second age
more important than that though lindon
is a very complex and important place
that plays a vital role in many of
middle earth's stories
it sits in the western reaches of the
continent right next to the area that
eventually becomes the shire
it's also the place that grey havens are
located which is where frodo and bilbo
sail from into the west at the end of
return of the king
in the second age lindon is one of the
most powerful kingdoms in middle earth
as sauron's darkness spreads across the
world it becomes a beacon of hope
to the free peoples who stand against
the dark lord ruled by the elven king
gilgalad
lindon also plays a key role in forging
crucial alliances with men and other
elves and ultimately provides much of
the muscle needed to topple sauron at
the end of the age
the last sentence of the synopsis states
that the show will also take viewers to
the breathtaking island kingdom of
numenor
the involvement of this island nation of
men was a foregone conclusion from the
first moment the second age was
confirmed
nevertheless knowing that numenor will
get its fair share of the spotlight
as exciting news for fans of tolkien's
legendarium the godlike beings known as
the valar give the island to its
inhabitants early in the second age and
the men of numenor continued to flourish
there for centuries
the men of numenor eventually get
tangled up with the events on the
mainland
and for a while become the focus of
sauron's obsession unfortunately the
dark lord's machinations ultimately lead
to the total destruction of the island
and the near extinction of its people
one of the final lines in the synopsis
reveals that the show's characters will
go to the furthest reaches of the map
this is a particularly interesting
statement as it can basically mean one
of two things
this could be a veiled reference to the
blessed realm of oman the land that lies
hidden in the west
this is where the valar and the elves
live in blissful harmony and it's also
where middle
earth's elves sail after their time on
the continent comes to an end
otherwise known as the undying lands
this continent and its blessed dwellings
are a focal point to the first age of
middle-earth however valinor also plays
a role in the events of the second age
most notably with regards to the
eventual downfall of numenor
on the other hand the synopsis could be
referring to the eastern regions of
middle earth
these are areas of the map that were
hardly ever explored even by tolkien
himself
however sauron's influence is
particularly strong in these lands and
the dark lord recruits
many of his soldiers from their
inhabitants if the amazon show does head
in this direction it's likely that
tolkien fans will get to experience a
side of middle earth they've never seen
before
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one